uh despite uh cop 27's climate Focus
their war in Ukraine is also arousing
strong feelings there on Tuesday
activists disrupted an event hosted by
the Russian delegation to protest
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and the
export of Russian fossil fuels
[Music]
no respect no
[Music]
and in that video we saw Dominica La
Sota she's a climate and social justice
activist and joins us now from charmel
Sheikh Dominica what exactly did you
hope to achieve there
we first of all wanted to disrupt the
panel because we think that you know if
Russian Federation hopes to have some
kind of uh public opening at an
International Conference and convince us
that they are doing something good for
our future for our safety they are very
wrong we went there and we protested at
the very beginning of that event the
Russian Federation here has 150
delegates including three um I think
including Authority fossil fuel
representatives and so for us it's
obvious that war criminals have no space
at Summits like this and so for them
from our side there was absolutely no
agreement for this panel to to go ahead
but in your view how can Reliance on for
example Russian fossil fuels be avoided
in the short term there's the winter
coming up here in Europe
yeah I think you know the Embargo will
not happen from one week to to another
but what we're seeing right now is the
situation where Europe has got itself
tied to Europe's biggest dictator of
protein and I think we must ramp up our
efforts to cut ourselves from Russian
gas most importantly in Germany here has
an incredible stake in that because so
far it Still Remains the biggest sponsor
of Russian war machine and despite the
energy challenges we have to keep going
because the Russian attacks are
incredibly strong and they are killing
ukrainians as we speak this winter in
order to survive we have to do
everything to ensure Heating and for
people across Europe we know that in
countries like mine in Poland the energy
poverty rates will rise extremely high
and so we have to provide the citizens
with any sort of safety but we must
finally start acknowledging that this
these ties to dictators and to their
fossil fuel energy means no energy
security for anyone and this has to be a
wake-up call for us to ramp up just
transition to put those heat pumps there
to put the solar panels on every rooftop
possible and to provide us and finally
pursue climate action which is the
solution also to this deadly Reliance on
dictator's a good team uh yeah but in
the short term uh what can be done
in the short term we have to cut our
energy demand we have to reduce the the
energy use so much energy and we waste
so much electricity and so we have to
reduce that so much so that you know
that Reliance on on putting and other
dictators is as small as possible and I
mean and can countries like Poland for
instance you know we have many bills
that are blocking wind energy and other
renewable energies that could already
within weeks or months be implemented be
unblocked and because they could fill in
that Gap that we have right now because
of putting sabotages obviously this
winter I think will be lost and it might
be one of the the the most tragic
Winters we will face is Europe but I
really do hope that if this winter is
lost the next year we have to do
everything to stop the money for to put
in to stop the Reliance on other
dictators and to finding phase those
fossil fuel rules
the climate and social justice activist
Dominica Lakota there thank you very
much Dominica
thank you
the eu's climate Chief says there is
still
in the negotiations that the United
Nations cup 27 climate Summit but the
clock is ticking for delicates in Egypt
to come to an agreement on climate goals
by Friday when the summit ends one of
the main sticking points compensation
for Nations most vulnerable to climate
change but the talks have just been
bolstered by world leaders at the G20
Summit who pledged to quote pursue
efforts to curb global warming to 1.5
degrees Centigrade
and DW correspondent Julia saudeli is at
the climate conference in charmele
Sheikh and she told me how the G20
declaration is being received there
well certainly it is seen as a positive
signal that the G20 countries have again
committed to trying to keep the rise of
global temperatures under 1.5 degrees
Celsius this is a goal that was set in
the Paris agreement in 2015 and we've
seen some signs here at the climate
conference that some countries might be
wavering on wanting to be as ambitious
to pursue this goal and it's important
for the G20 countries to have uh again
committed to the 1.5 degree goal and it
is also important that the G20 countries
said that they want to push for reaching
an agreement on loss and damage that is
a compensation for the country's most
affected by the consequences of climate
change and that is something that uh is
like to be well received here too okay
now I believe DW has also been talking
to the eu's chief climate negotiator
Franz timmermans about rich countries
paying poor countries more for of the
damage to the climate
yes this is exactly one of the biggest
topics here at the climate conference
how can countries come to an agreement
looking at rich countries contributing
financially to cover the great damage
that the most vulnerable and poor
countries are having to carry the burden
of because of climate change and we
asked uh
Timmerman's what he thought exactly
about this issue let's hear what he told
us because some countries want that
money to go to all developing countries
and the European Union wants this money
to go to those countries who are most
vulnerable as a result of the climate
crisis so we need to find a way through
that everybody can agree that this money
will go to the countries that need it
most and we also need to talk about the
conditions some countries want a
specific fund for this that could be a
solution we are open to that but we also
want to explore other possible solutions
because creating a fund takes many years
and we want to start helping vulnerable
countries now and perhaps there are
other solutions to address the issue but
we are open to discussing that and
finding a compromise so that we can have
a successful conclusion about loss and
damage here in charmelecheck
Julia I do just have to ask you um
Brazil's president-elect Lula to Silver
is at the climate talks and he's taking
a very different approach to The Climate
from his uh his predecessor Jaya
boltonaro isn't he
yeah there's a lot of excitement for
Lula's presence here at the cop 27 and
especially because it does Mark A New
Beginning for Brazil it's a message
saying that Brazil is back and uh
definitely more attention by Lula to the
issues of the climate protection of the
Amazon and other countries here at cop
excited to be able to work together
again and in closer relationships with
Brazil exactly on this on this topic and
ready to cooperate more closely with
Brazil at this point
DW's Judas sardelli insham elf Sheikh
thank you so much for that
one way to slow climate change is to
rely more on renewable energy and that's
where wind turbines come in they can be
effective if there's enough wind but the
size and noise Make Them unpopular with
local residents now a totally new more
compact design could improve their
reputation its creators hope the
wiggling turbines will revolutionize the
landscape
flickering Shadows infrasound a death
trap for Birds critics are finding lots
of reasons to oppose ever larger wind
farms here's an alternative a bladeless
pole-shaped turbine wind generates
electricity through vibrations alone
almost silently the inspiration the
collapse of the Tacoma Bridge in the U.S
in 1940 a structure undone by wind
using a homemade wind tunnel David Yanez
developed his first weakling wind
turbines
[Music]
the generator sits in the center this is
the part that converts motion into
electricity that's it a slim structure
round very simple no gears no bearings
No mechanics it just converts motion
energy into electricity
sounds simple but it wasn't Vortex early
years were Rocky and energy output was
low
back then there was nothing on the
internet for wind turbines without
blades there were no examples for us to
learn from other than basic physics
but with government and European funding
the team went further developing a
larger wind tunnel and power plant about
two and a half meters high it creates
100 watts of power
the turbine can now provide energy for a
home a single family home for instance
could have three or four solar panels on
the roof additionally there could be one
or two plateless turbines to provide the
Basic Energy needs at night
the decisive advantage of the wiggling
wind turbines they can be put in
populated areas even cities but before
Mass producing these turbines Vortex is
going one step further
they received an order from Saudi Arabia
for larger versions The destined for
neum the new city in the middle of the
desert which is currently being built
four of them will be shipped soon
they've given us this wonderful
opportunity to build turbines seven and
eight meters high this is a great
opportunity for us to learn more and
develop the technology even further
once the large prototypes are finished
mass production of these mid-sized
turbines is getting closer perhaps they
will be available for purchase early
next year